we want to be with you all for real so I
took the helmet off delayed the batons
down I want to make this a parade so you
put down your stuff and you're walking
with everyone and what is the reaction
among people around you it was electric
you had people that had no face and in
one moment they saw that the police were
with them and again I'm not a hero I'm
not a I'm not somebody that duh that
wants to get any attention individually
but you know it takes police leadership
it takes experience and training but
more importantly takes the heart of a
human being to show love and dignity and
respect for another human being and all
the folks wanted it was someone to hear
them not to just whisper words and it
takes the cops to come from behind their
desks from outside their conference
rooms from outside their podiums from
the top down in to go into the community
and I can tell you that this to those
folks there or street-smart and when you
are in a community and you try to say
something and it doesn't come from here
folks pick it up quick and they knew
that the heart was right because I grew
up in jail I grew up as a police officer
27 years tomorrow's my anniversary so I
understand people I've been on the
mission field I understand pain and all
I wanted to these folks to just know
that that I'm here for you these cops
are here for you and 800,000 cops around
the United States are here for you and
that's what they took it in I'm telling
you we talked all the way a mile and a
half you hung out back at the Target
store in the last two days we have
demonstrations zero arrests zero
fighters and zero injuries
[Applause]
explain to me what happened what was
going on before you even joined the
protest what was going on they started
marching up a street that's only there
that these to the police department and
that's when the temperature changed
everybody felt it you can adhere the
dispatch that was putting out where
they're moving increase in anxiety
people got their battle gear on myself
included I'm a frontline leader so I'm
not I'm out there and I saw this whole
thing happening and I seriously thought
to myself how do we get here like all
the good we've done for so we we've
overcome so much in Flint's we did all
this good in one instant it was God that
trust in police went from hero to
villain and I saw the attention and I
could feel the anger and as the line was
there to push against the people you
know it was it was right enough is it
ready to pop the end down you know
there's fear on the protesters side and
there's fear of the cop side because we
know what the potential is and then I
saw a fist pump and I saw a little small
hug and I was like that's it
I'm gonna talk to these folks so they
laid the protons down I took off my
helmet and I walked in the middle of the
crowd and I found his chat collar and I
said brother I'm telling you that guy
doesn't represent who we are who these
cops are I gave him a big old hug and I
said what do you need he goes tell the
people I said you get their attention
and uh as he yelled out everybody
Sheriff's wants to talk and they all
turn don't think for a second that he
represents who these cops are from all
over the county and around the station
and they said without even thinking walk
with us and that was the moment that put
Flynn on the map we're right just anger
is used for a peaceful demonstration and
not the burn and torts our city what has
been the reaction from the community
well first I give great great great
honor to the protesters and the ones
that were leading it we're fluid strong
we're flute proud and I'm telling that
that spread we set a tone that you can
be the beacon of light you
and be the trendsetter and and I feel my
heart breaks for communities that didn't
see when I was able to see an experience
that night bro what would your message
be to those other communities especially
the big cities where you have you know
you have violence going on right now
what would your message be clearly it's
turned from peaceful protest into a riot
they have to respond I got to protect
human life I got to protect businesses
and houses and and that's in a tough
spot but my message is we need to lay
down our stores on both sides we need it
calm we need police leadership to
continue to go and not just go us every
single day we need to root out bad cops
because there's no such thing you can't
have a bad cop on your office or in your
department you got to get them out and
when that means get them out that means
fire or charged get him out for the
protesters give him a chance to speak
George
Floyd changed American policing forever
above all the things that happened he
was the pinnacle of all those other
unnecessary deaths that we've seen since
the 90s in before but that was a tipping
point people said enough is enough it is
time to make change and I'm Tony from a
cop's perspective the burden falls on us
the burden falls on us
[Music]